laviolette et la ville rose une image
cartes postales qui a bien failli
disparaître
pourtant le parfum de cette fleur est
unique et attire de nombreux admirateurs
malgré un gros rhume sans personne
n'arrive à sentir ça je peux vous le
certifier
c'est sur ce tour les premiers rayons du
printemps du soleil je lis la violer tu
resteras violette de toulouse de
toulouse évidemment mais l'accent ne
fait pas tout et surtout pas l'unanimité
chez les fleuristes
je n'ai pas je ne la fait pas pourtant
les producteurs s'y intéressent à
nouveau
ils ne sont plus qu'une dizaine au lieu
de 250 dans les années fastes d'après
guerre
ceux qui ont subsisté ont suivi
l'évolution de la culture hors sol plus
saines mieux contrôler que la culture en
pleine terre mais la violer ce nécessite
toujours de la main d'oeuvre et prend du
temps pour s'épanouir
celui ci c'est celui que nous venons
s'est amené sur la csu que nous valons
l'an prochain d'où le coup un petit peu
élevé de la houlette de tony la vente en
peau assez récente celle estime d'une
plus longue vie faut-il encore pouvoir
faire face à la concurrence
actuellement nous sommes à peu près à 50
mille plants et il faudrait pour que ce
soit significatif représenter de la 300
mille plants voila voila un petit peu
l'objectif c'est à dire multiplier par
trois ou quatre la production actuelle
et la violette pourrait ainsi donner une
autre couleur à la ville rose
car il est une chose certaine les
amoureux toulousain ne pourront jamais
s'en passer
là nous